we're on problem 48 it says if x squared
is added to x the sum is 42. so let's
just write that out if x squared
is added to x
the sum is equal to 42 which of the
following could be the value of x so
essentially they just want us to solve
this equation so the easiest way to do
it is to write it as a
as a quadratic equaling 0 and then
factoring it so we could write this as x
squared
plus
x minus 42 is equal to zero and let's
think what two numbers when i add them
equal one
and when i multiply them equal minus 42
and the fact that when i multiply them
equals minus 42 tells me that one of
them has to be positive and one of them
has to be negative that's the only way
that you're gonna when you multiply two
numbers you're gonna have a negative
number so one of them has to be positive
one of them has to be negative and so
when we're adding a positive and a
negative you're really finding the
difference between the two so the
difference between the two numbers has
to be one and the product has to be 42
and i notice when i see 42 i immediately
think oh 6 and 7 6 times 7 is 42
and since when you add them you get a
positive one 7 is probably the positive
one and
and the minus 6 or six is probably the
negative one so let's try it out
x
plus seven
times x minus six
equal to zero
and right seven times minus six is minus
42 and then 7 it's really 7x plus
minus 6x is equal to positive x we could
sing 7 plus minus 6 is equal to the
coefficient of x which is 1.
but anyway that works and you can
multiply this out and try it out and all
everything i'm saying i'm not you know
it's not some voodoo the reason why i i
say that they have to add up to the one
is because when you multiply this out
that's what builds up this term the
seven times x
plus the minus six times the other x
that's what builds this term when you
multiply it out right this term comes
from the x times the x the minus 42
comes from the seven times the minus six
anyway now we're at this point we say
okay well how do we get this we have two
things when you multiply them equal to
zero well that means that one of them or
both of them have to be equal to zero so
that means that
x plus seven is equal to zero
which would mean subtract seven from
both sides which means x is equal to
minus seven
or
x minus 6 is equal to 0
add 6 to both sides x is equal to 6. x
would be 6 or minus 7
and they have one of the choices there
which was choice a
next problem
49 what quantity should be added to both
sides of this equation to complete the
square so when you complete the square
you want the thing to just look like a
you want that what's ever on the
left-hand side to look like a perfect
square what do i mean by a perfect
square so
you know if i had x plus a
squared that's equal to x plus a
times x plus a
and that's equal to x times x x squared
x times that a
so that's plus ax and now this a times
this x so that's another ax
plus this a times that a so plus a
squared and that's equal to x squared
plus we have two of these now plus two
ax
plus a squared so essentially we want
this
we want the left hand side to have this
form so we say oh this is a perfect
square we can say that's the same thing
as x plus a squared so let's think about
how we can do it
if we have
x squared
minus eight x
is equal to five and i put
a space here for a reason because we
wanna add or subtract something here so
it looks like a perfect square
so think about it whatever when we when
we have this format right
in order for this thing to be a perfect
square
whatever this coefficient is right here
this term right here has to be half of
this squared right a squared is half of
2a squared so if we took half of minus 8
that's minus 4 right in this case if we
said 2a is equal to 8 a would be minus
4.
and so minus 4 squared is what it's plus
16
plus 16. and this is an equation so one
thing you do to one side of an equation
you have to do the other side of the
equation so you have to say that that is
also equal to so you have to add 16 to
both sides otherwise you're changing the
equation
anyway now this hopefully you recognize
this is already a perfect square i mean
you could look at this pattern up here
or you could say okay if i add minus 4
to itself twice i get minus 8. if i
multiply it by itself it gets 16. so
this is x minus 4
squared
and that's equal to
25. and actually just so if you're
curious and we did this in the khan
academy we did a couple of videos on
this this is how you prove the quadratic
equation you essentially complete the
square with you know arbitrary numbers a
b and c and you get the quadratic
equation and it's not you know we show
it in 10 minutes so it's not this you
know
impossibly hard thing to understand but
if you have to they just want to know
what to you what do you add to both
sides of this equation right what
quantity should be added to both sides
of this equation to complete the square
so the answer to this one was 16.
but they just as equally could have said
you know solve it by completing the
square and you say oh x minus 4 squared
is equal to 25 so x minus 4 is equal to
plus or minus 5 and then you could say x
is equal to plus or minus five plus four
and then you could say okay
which is four plus positive five is nine
four plus minus five is
or minus one anyway they didn't ask us
that so we don't have to spend too much
time thinking about it
see
we're on problem
50
let me see
problem 50. i'll copy and paste 50 and
51.
50 and 51.
all right
what are the solutions for the quadratic
equation x squared plus 6x is equal to
16.
x squared
plus 6x is equal to 16. and the
temptation here is really to kind of try
to solve it the way you do a linear
equation i don't know factor out an x
and i don't know whatever else but the
important thing to recognize is this is
a quadratic equation and the easiest way
to solve it is to put all the terms on
one side and then get a zero on the
other side and then either factor it or
use the actual quadratic equation
or you know complete the square whatever
you need to do so let's subtract 16 from
both sides and you get x squared plus 6x
minus 16 is equal to zero right i just
subtracted 16 from both sides to get
here
and before just jumping into the
quadratic equation let's see if we can
factor it by inspection so what two
numbers when i
when i add them equal
six
and went positive six and when i
subtract when i multiply them equal nine
is sixteen
and once again since it's a minus
sixteen if you multiply two numbers you
get a negative number
they have to be different signs one has
to be positive and one has to be
negative
and and and their difference will be six
because once positive one is negative so
let me think about it so if i had minus
well eight and two is equal to 16 and
they're 6 apart so if i did plus 8 and
minus 2 right plus 8 minus 2 is positive
6.
so it's
x
plus 8
times x minus 2. and that really just
takes a lot of practice you say okay
what two numbers 16 okay eight and two
well they're gonna have to be different
signs so but i have a positive one here
so whichever number is larger is
probably going to be the positive one so
positive eight minus two yeah when you
add them up they equal minus six yeah it
works
so you get that equal to zero
and you say okay this has to be equal to
zero or that has to be equal to zero so
x is eq so x is either equal to minus
eight right
if you say x plus eight is equal to zero
then subtract 8 from both sides you get
x is equal to minus 8. i shouldn't have
skipped that step but i'll do the step
here or you could say x minus 2 is equal
to 0.
add 2 to both sides you get x is equal
to 2. you know what what x e makes this
term equal 0 and you can look at it from
inspection so x could either be minus 8
or 2
and that is choice
c
problem 51.
leanne correctly solved the equation
x squared plus 4x equals 6 by completing
the square
which equation is part of our solution
okay so same thing we just have to x
squared plus 4x and when you complete
the square you're going to add something
here so i'm going to leave a little
blank is equal to 6.
so what could i add here that makes this
expression look like a perfect square
well we go the pattern that we did a
couple of problems ago
whatever is here should be the square of
half of this
so 4 well half of that is 2 2 squared is
4 so i should add 4 to that side if i
add 4 to that i'd have to add 4 to this
side as well
and then this
2 plus 2 is equal to 4 2 times 2 is
equal to 4. so this is x plus 2 squared
and i really want you to get the
intuition don't memorize the steps for
completing square i want you to really
understand why what you know this is the
square of half of that we showed it in
the beginning you know square a lot of
binomials and see for yourself that
that's always going to be the case
anyway so this is x plus 2 squared and
it's going to be equal to 6 plus 4 is
equal to 10.
and that is
choice b
choice b
i think we have time for one more
one more problem problem 52
copied it and now i have pasted it
carter is solving this equation by
factoring which expression could be one
of his correct factors
all right once again i like to i like to
personally separate out the
the um
a number that goes into all of them and
all of these are divisible by five that
just simplifies it in my head so if i
divide all of these by 5 actually i can
just divide both sides of this equation
by 5 right 0 divided by 5 is 0 and then
the left side divided by 5 becomes
2
x squared
minus
5 x
minus five x plus three
is equal to
zero
okay so this is two x squared here so
it's going to be two numbers when you
multiply them equal three
and when you so let's think about this a
little bit
let me write it actually let me write it
down here because i think i'll need more
space
two x squared minus five x plus three is
equal to zero and i just divided both
sides of this equation by 5 to get to
this
so let's see if we can what we can do
here
so we have a 2x squared here and they
already kind of hinted us that we're
going to have an integer solutions that
we can factor this so the intuition is
that this is going to be 2x
times you know plus something plus a
times well what times
times probably x right 2x times x is 2x
squared
now that wouldn't be completely obvious
if they didn't already tell us that you
know we could factor this you might have
to use a quadratic equation or something
actually the quadratic equation wouldn't
be something crazy to use here because
you can just kind of plug and charge but
let's see if we can get the intuition so
it's going to be 2x plus something
times x plus something else
and if we were to multiply this out you
get 2x times x is 2x squared as it
should 2x times b is plus 2 bx a times x
is plus ax a times b is plus
a b and so let's see what we get
we get
we get a
so plus
2 b
plus a
x
plus a b
2x squared
okay now we can do pattern matching
right this was our original thing
so 2 times b plus a have to be equal to
right this term is the same thing as
this term right here and that term has
to be the same thing as that term right
there
so what two numbers so first of all
i have a positive three here
so i'm multiplying two numbers to get a
positive three so they either have to be
both positive or both negative right
and then the other interesting thing is
we have when i take two times one of
them plus the other one i get a minus a
negative number so the only way when
you're dealing with negative numbers and
you know when you just multiply it times
a positive and add them to each other
you get another negative number is if
they're if they're both negative right
this told us they both have to be
negative because this is positive and
then since when you add them in a kind
of you know without any negative signs
you get a negative number it tells you
that that has to be negative as well
so let's see let's just try 3 and
negative 3 and negative 1.
so if we have negative
if negative 3 negative 1. so you're
right yeah if b
if b is
b is equal to -1 and a is equal to -3
then 2 times minus 1 is minus 2
minus 3 right so b is equal to -1 and a
is equal to minus 3. so this this is a
bit of a
of an art form here i mean there isn't
like a plug and chug very mechanical way
of doing this the quadratic equation is
one but this is the best way that at
least i know how to do these without
so we know what a and b is so it's two
x
a is minus three two x minus three
times
x plus b b is minus one
so that's the factorization
and what are they
so two x minus three times x minus one
which one they have this one right here
two x minus three
and i'm all out of time see in the next
video